[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que damos la palabra a
artistas deportistas gente del mundo de
las ciencias las artes la política y de
la sociedad civil américa latina es una
de las regiones más urbanizadas del
mundo ocho de cada diez personas viven
en una ciudad según cifras del banco
mundial para las autoridades así como
para los 650 millones de pobladores
habitan esas ciudades sus ciudades
constituye un desafío gigantesco
permanente para hablar de ello de cómo
está evolucionando la urbanización en
latinoamérica de las situaciones y
alternativas que se han venido
presentando contamos con la presencia de
nuestros estudios de janeiro wilson
arquitecta y doctora en urbanismo co
directora del libro habitar las ciudades
latinoamericanas publicadas
recientemente por la editorial
l'harmattan ya neira bienvenida a esta
escala en parís gracias por venir a
nuestros estudios y gracias a ustedes
para la invitación a hablar de ciudades
latinoamericanas
presenta una serie de temas una serie de
estudios muy concretos de diversas
experiencias que se han vivido en
américa latina' antes de analizar esas
experiencias presenta yo quisiera
preguntarle por qué es importante el
estudio del habitar en tanto que tal
pues el estudio del habitar es
importante porque contempla una cantidad
de procesos políticos sociales que
tienen que ver no nada más con el tema
de la vivienda o con el tema de
donde podemos estar sino las relaciones
que podemos establecer entre los
individuos y con respecto a las
situaciones actuales del medio ambiente
que son importantes tener en cuenta
habitar pues es un proceso no es un
estado decir una situación en constante
evolución que entiendo bien ciudades
grandes hay muchas megalópolis hay
muchos que es lo que hace la
particularidad de las grandes urbes
latinoamericanas
por supuesto que es un proceso y en ese
proceso
tendremos tendencia a decir que las
ciudades latinoamericanas tienen una
particularidad de reaccionar con
bastante fuerza
son bastantes reactivas con respecto a
la cantidad de movimientos sociales que
sean que se han generado en procesos
distintos procesos políticos tenemos
tendencia a
si considero que la particularidad es la
fuerte reactividad que pueda tenerse y
de volver a estar en mejores situaciones
independientemente de lo que ocurra
genera antes de comenzar nuestro
programa usted me comentaba y decíamos
el libro en la que estamos hablando fue
el resultado de un coloquio en el que
participaron miembros y representantes
de toda latinoamérica ustedes no se
esperaban el número de contribuciones
que recibieron desde experiencia y si
fue una gran sorpresa porque
inicialmente cuando uno hace este tipo
de llamados a proyectos y en este caso
que era sobre las ciudades
latinoamericanas
pensamos que íbamos a recibir unos 40-50
respuestas y llegamos a recibir casi 500
lo que nos hizo pues dedicarnos
completamente a tratar de buscar otros
recursos y que el coloquio llegara
a transformar completamente los estudios
urbanos que tenían unas referencias
bastante más antiguas y como pudimos
colocar sobre el tapiz una cantidad de
estudios urbanos actuales sobre la
financiarización sobre los problemas
urbanos del tipo del medioambiente las
políticas actuales de vivienda y bueno
sí fue una gran sorpresa y el libro es
el resultado de ese recorrido que
comenzamos enhorabuena precisamente este
libro habitar las ciudades
latinoamericanas decíamos analiza varias
experiencias una que llama mi atención
es la de la agricultura militante que se
da en sao paulo en brasil concretamente
y que consiste entre otras cosas en
ocupar espacios vamos a decir públicos
sin la autorización de las autoridades
correspondientes porque fue retenido
este tipo de experiencia que lo que
aporta este tipo de casos por ejemplo si
bueno ese trabajo de nagy propone un
estudio de
las relaciones más en un sistema de
horizontalidad con las políticas
públicas es decir en qué momento los
espacios públicos pueden ser ocupados
por
una actividad distinta y que es
gerenciada por los habitantes se trataba
de mostrar como la agricultura urbana
forma parte de un militante ismo y que
puede tener un impacto dentro de los
decidores del de la ciudad habitar
habitar significa también ocupar un
espacio una morada en el caso de usted
ya me dirá usted viene de venezuela
presenta un estudio bastante interesante
sobre la experiencia de los programas de
construcción de vivienda primero bajo el
gobierno del presidente hugo chávez más
recientemente bajo la dirección del
presidente maduro y lo que se destaca es
que no sólo hay una ideologización de
este tipo de programas sino claramente
una utilización y dijéramos una cuestión
muy productivista qué quiere decir con
esto
pues quiere decir que en el momento que
chávez llega al poder se genera una
cantidad de lo que se llaman unas
misiones que son unas estructuras
paralelas a las estructuras políticas de
políticas públicas glass y robert exacto
y que tratan de resolver los problemas
de alimentación
sanidad vivienda y en el caso de
venezuela un país de 30 millones de
habitantes que tiene una que sufre una
crisis multifacética donde hay 5
millones de personas han huido del país
o han salido del país se propone una
construcción de 5 millones de viviendas
es y si estimamos un radio de 4 personas
por vivienda es tim haríamos que 20
millones de personas estarían viviendo
en ese programa de vivienda social es el
total de la población ya exacto y la
particularidad es que en esa producción
hay una cantidad de símbolos y de
imágenes como puede ser la firma de
chávez en las fachadas del edificio o
los ojos que están tanto las fachadas
como el interior de los apartamentos y
es lo que marcel mauss habla de la
creación de una deuda que en el caso de
venezuela tanta clara entre la deuda que
se genera una nueva deuda o relación que
se genera entre el estado y las personas
que son beneficiarias de esas viviendas
hay todo lo que yo llamo un marketing
político territorial a través de tratar
de dar
oportunidad a acceso a ciertos derechos
fundamentales pero con una ideología que
pues abarca un espacio bastante
importante está como trasfondo y que
está presente también en el fondo de la
escena exactamente visible ya de ir a
habitar y habitar plantea una serie de
contradicciones el caso que me viene más
rápidamente a la mente es por ejemplo
justamente entre el transporte público
el uso del automóvil el vivir en una
casa y vivir en un edificio de
condominios cómo se equilibra esta
situación precisamente en el hábitat de
la ciudad latinoamericana
si el equilibrio es bastante frágil es
decir hay momentos en los que hay muchas
iniciativas colectivas para tratar de
agrupar y poder tener ciertos servicios
que puedan disminuir el consumo excesivo
del vehículo o como utilizar el espacio
de la tierra de una manera que pueda
aprovecharse mejor su uso y su consumo y
es por ello que pues se benefician
ciertos espacios más colectivos y eso
tiene que ver con incluso la manera en
la que nos vamos relacionando hoy día yo
creo que incluso con con la pandemia que
vimos hace poco es inevitable que
tenemos que seguir profundizando sobre
cuáles son esos mecanismos de ocupación
del espacio si es
para ir más hacia ese uso del transporte
colectivo o todo el desarrollo que vemos
actuales de las de las movilidades
dulces como le llaman como el uso de la
bicicleta o
otros transportes que pueden ser menos
dañinos al planeta como se puede
distinguir una la construcción de una
verdad verdadera autonomía de una
verdadera alternativa de lo que es
ponerle un parche a la ausencia de
política estatal
pienso que el tema del parche viene en
el momento en el que de igual manera los
problemas estructurales no son
comprendidos por las políticas públicas
es decir cuando no hay consultación
cuando no hay una inclusión de las
personas que requieren los servicios y
cuando el estado o el estado o la o el
privado trata de dar una respuesta que
no corresponde a esa necesidad
básicamente es un parche y es una es una
respuesta que no corresponde a las
personas no se van a apropiar del
sistema y generalmente va a funcionar de
una manera inadecuada comentaba usted
hace unos momentos la que haya sido la
experiencia no sólo de latinoamérica
sino a nivel internacional del
surgimiento de la pandemia la necesidad
de adaptarse como burgués a este tipo de
situación en el caso de latinoamérica lo
decimos está en un proceso de
urbanización muy acelerado no sólo está
la resurgencia de pandemias cada vez de
manera más recurrentes está también el
problema entre otras cosas de la escasez
de agua del cambio climático hay alguna
ciudad que usted pudiese citar esté a la
vanguardia que pueda servir un poco
modelo de lo que son las posibilidades
de adaptarse precisamente esos enormes
desafíos
creo que podríamos citar el caso de
mendoza argentina o incluso en el caso
de ciudad de mexico como existen ciertos
movimientos igual políticos o colectivos
donde
tratan de poner en valor el uso del agua
como un recurso o incluso
ecuador también como un recurso valioso
sagrado y que empiezan a cuestionar
ciertas políticas del uso del agua en
que existen clásicamente y cómo pueden
ser distribuidas de otra manera
me parece que el tema de la comprensión
del uso y del valor del recurso
en esas ciudades está siendo un poco más
estudiado oh oh sí puesto en el debate
para que sea un derecho más de la parte
de los habitantes y no de gestión del
estado
supone esto en la situación actual de
latinoamérica y no solo que se tendría
que luchar como alternativa para que el
agua sea un derecho social realmente y
no escapará lo que son los procesos de
privatización que se han visto en países
de américa latina sí claro yo creo que
el tema del agua es como cuando se
hablan de todos estos modelos
neoliberales incluso con respecto al
consumo del agua donde el que la
gestiona es más el privado o unas
empresas mixtas o el estado y bastante
excluido está el usuario o los
habitantes de ciertos de ciertas
comunidades o de la ciudad no entonces
si es ver cómo puede darse más valor a
quien la gestiona y cómo se usa y que no
sea tan desvinculado tanto del estado
como como como los usuarias ya neira
wilson cuáles serían algunos de los
principales desafíos que tendrán que
enfrentar estas megalópolis estas
grandes urbes latinoamericanas en el
corto plazo y hemos citado algunos casos
el cambio climático la escases de agua
pero sabemos que hay otros más
tal vez ni siquiera son considerados el
problema del tratamiento de la basura
por ejemplo el problema en transporte
público pero hacia donde tendría que
enfrentarse orientarse esas urbes esas
poblaciones para resolver estos enormes
desafíos que tendrán frente a ellas en
el corto plazo bueno los desafíos como
bien lo acaba de decir tienen que ver
con todos estos problemas que además yo
creo que es importante agregar la parte
política y todos estos cambios que están
ocurriendo en américa latina que pues
requieren una atención y una
participación bastante más importante de
la parte de todos los habitantes
considero que hay que estar más activo
en las acciones a tomar sobre lo que
está ocurriendo en el cotidiano y pues
de repente podríamos abarcar esos
desafíos de una manera más óptima pues
estamos llegando ya al final de este
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerles ryanair a wilson doctora en
la arquitectura y una de las directoras
de la obra habitar en las ciudades
latinoamericanas su presencia en
nuestros estudios ustedes gracias por
esta cita con escala en parís
[Música]